hey Vsauce Michael here and I'm flying
to Dallas today to see my sister but
until then I thought it might be fun to
show you a handful of the over 200
videos I made before Vsauce that way you
can get to know me a little bit more
intimately the first video I ever made
was actually for a class in college it
was a mash-up of two movies Ferris
Bueller's Day Off and Friday the 13th I
also made this rap video mashup starring
george w bush and karl rove next i moved
on to making complicated artistic
cultural pieces on a new channel
campaign 2008 such as this masterpiece
hillary clinton farts you often avoid
taking firm positions on controversial
issues
I didn't have a girlfriend my senior
year of college so I spent the time
teaching myself editing techniques while
making Obama sing like a Bollywood star
for my video Barack Obama would but love
was still in my heart and that's why I
edited this video where I made it look
like Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton
kissed
I also cut Mitt Romney to do an old
episode of Gilligan's Island and made it
look like he was creeping on the girls
around that time I started doing work
for barely political editing and re
mixing my own stuff and even some stuff
by other people like the songs by Mark
Douglas I also got to revisit Hillary
Clinton's gastrointestinal problems this
time with a cameo by John McCain hello
when the election was over I summarized
it in a remix built out of the original
Mario Brothers you can see Obama take on
pundits and even score himself at Joe
Biden power up when YouTube introduced
annotations I was there and in March of
2009 I built an interactive Chris Brown
punch-out game across 30 different
videos on barely arcade in the game you
can choose to throw things at him to
score points like of course burning dog
poop a few months and dozens of remixes
later I started editing compilation
videos along with music from Jake shut
now like this one where I counted down
my 51 favorite kid fails I also played
bass guitar with rusty in his world of
warcraft inspired van Ford Zeppelin
and before he was doing auto-tune the
news I directed and edited a few videos
with Michael Gregory there's good old
Jake there's Andrew and here I come
riding on a space lock and late this
year I was still being like this video
where I made it look like Obama was
smoking the natural next move of course
was to make Justin Bieber's head explode
and while Tom small was on vacation I
directed and edited electronic was for
the kiosk to tickle my butt cheeks a nun
flies through the sky but here's the
news story Vsauce 2 that's right before
the sauce completely overflows on one
channel I've started the second channel
Vsauce 2 will really kick up after the
holidays but you can go over there right
now to check out an episode of my new
show loot I'm playing around with it
still but it's a lot like IMG except
everything I cover is for sale so what
are you waiting for go over to Vsauce to
subscribe check out loot and as always
thanks for watching